that's not that's right who's the
biggest liars middle one
men men lie to most women tell the
biggest lie we lie all the time we lost
so much as damn near language it's right
to call a man out for life it's like
playing basketball with a [ __ ] kid
and calling for double dribble
you gotta let some [ __ ] slide you just
gotta let some [ __ ] slide man we love
all the time we love all the time you
know the man's lines like the man's lies
like I was at Tony house I make in a
house that's a man's life a woman's lies
like it's your baby
[Applause]
well we've all heard that long hey don't
even look like me
oh he's got your hat that's right who's
the biggest lies women the biggest lies
biggest I look at you all of you your
[ __ ] lie
you're all liars
alia [ __ ] lines masters of the life
the visual life look at you you got all
heels you ain't that time you gotta make
up your face to look like that
you got a weave your head and love
you got a Wonderbra it didn't say that
bin everything about you is a lie and
you expect me to tell the truth [ __ ]
[Applause]
men lie with lie we live lies that's why
we're so crazy every now and then we
catch ourselves living a lie we create a
whole wide world around us
for instance every man in this room is
hiding some porno in his house
everything in here got a pornography
stash in the crib not an illegal amount
just enough to get you by and when we
had porno we go all out and it behind
the refrigerator under the bed no we
become Batman when it's time to hide
support oh that's right you hit the
light switch the whole bookshelf shift
to the side you go down two flights and
stares into your porno cell aha
Janet jacked me yes
Tobi car jenna jameson that's rough but
women always find the porn they'll
always find a porno but they don't find
it in the porno hiding place I don't
know no when a women find a porno ass
and a VCR but wait a minute there's one
exception there's one exception there's
one instance where white people could
say [ __ ] and I can let it out tonight
i'ma let it out here in Johannesburg
[Applause]
save me and white people like this is
what I paid for
[Applause]
so [ __ ] great night now the water
white people could save me here goes
listen closely cuz I may never say this
[ __ ] again but one time white people
could say [ __ ] ok it is Christmas Eve
and it's between 30 and 4 49 in the
moment if you like and you on your way
to Toys R Us to get your kid the last
transformer doll and then right before
you walk in the Toys R Us some black
person runs up beside you stop
[Laughter]
Rimma dances on your head take that you
cracker-ass [ __ ]
mama picked into quick s full of takes
your money s is Anya
and runs away if you write at that
moment you could say somebody
matter of fact is you worried and that
happens to you you can say [ __ ] for a
whole month but you got to walk around
with the police or poop in your pocket
chicks in and black people catch you
saying [ __ ] the police report will act
as your freedom papers hey I heard you
saying [ __ ] let me see your [ __ ]
papers give me the bag on Christmas Eve
[Applause]
Co 48
you just made it [ __ ] Estonian I
hope they catch that [ __ ] threat man
and everybody talking about gun control
God get rid of the guns like that I like
the rumors you got a gun you don't have
to work out hey look you know I ain't
jogging you got pecs I got texts
ah you don't need no gun control you
don't you need we need some bullet
control
beneath it maybe we need to control the
bullets that's where I think Oh foolish
it cost $5,000 beaucoup you know what
cuz if a bullet cost $5,000 there be no
more innocent bystander
every time somebody shot me like there
he musta did son sure they put Bennett
babanova on the bullets in his ass
[Applause]
and people before they killed somebody
for bullet cost five thousand thousand
man I would blow your [ __ ] head off
if I could afford it oh well give me
another job I'm gonna start saving some
money and you a dead man you better hope
I can't get no bullets on layaway so
even if you get shot by a stray bullet
you won't have to go to no doctor to get
it take it out whoever shot you think
they'd pull it back I believe you got my
property married and bored or single and
lonely that's right just like marriage
is some boring ass [ __ ] cuz once you get
married you're gonna hang around other
married people and that's just
disgusting
you ever go to dinner with six neutered
adults a bunch of women talking about
diaper genies and hair coloring
you don't believe it into luggage sting
shut the [ __ ] up
a bunch of men talking about barbecue
grills and routes to work you know
sometimes we'll take the highway but if
you backed up
I gots besides you son like to see they
get me there and half the time yeah you
should take it down i-95 and clear
something shut the [ __ ] up
I hate ferry babe oh it's [ __ ]
disgusting if you're gonna eat dinner
with single people single people eat for
hour in 30 minutes and leave cuz they
got [ __ ] to do married people closed
down a restaurant they stopped ordering
coffee and dessert stop talking to the
hockey tank I like to think it foot
right there stop talking to the cook the
tea water [ __ ]
hurry up we got a lot of not [ __ ] to
do if you hurry up we cannot [ __ ] all
night oh I hate married [ __ ] people
man
and fellas once you get married you
become your wife's pet you become a
[ __ ] bet because women like to get
their husbands together they don't even
know each other and have like a grown
man playdate put you in a room with some
other married [ __ ] because he
likes baseball just like you and you in
some room with some [ __ ] stranger I
like baseball
I like baseball too
yeah yeah baseball good yeah yeah honey
who the [ __ ] is this get me the [ __ ]
outta hell need no new friends if you
want to help me out introduce me to a
girl
I hate married people man whenever I go
out with other married couples I like to
bring along a single crackhead just a
spicing up activity come on tell us some
of your cracker tales please married
single
and only see the problem relationships
is people want too much man
people want too much everybody's looking
for soul mate soul mate we're so much
we're one we're soul mates I'm a Pisces
Aquarius for perfect we're soul mates
it's incredible it's because of his food
is my star this is so great
there's so many and we complete each
other we finish each other's sentences
and the other day was raining I said
honey it's get ready to write he said
raincoat it's amazing it's like we're
telekinesis we pelican eASIC it's a kind
of book like god
nobody gets your soulmate it don't
happen all you don't get in life if
you're lucky is a mate just to make
somebody a buck go to movies with you
[ __ ] go to another movie your [ __ ] go to
the comedy show you [ __ ] you're going to
grandmama house you [ __ ] you go to your
mama's house you [ __ ] go see another
movie and somewhere in between [ __ ]
and movies he goes Mookie Soni
and that's all relationships are ain't
that complicated
it's just [ __ ] and eating if you're
like [ __ ] somebody and you're like
any one of y'all don't need to be
together and the longer you wish
somebody is MOLLE in and less [ __ ]
[ __ ] you don't even remember the last
time you [ __ ] but you know you had rice
and beans on Wednesday you'll never go
get a soulmate
you never gonna meet the perfect person
you never gonna meet somebody in love
Seinfeld in the wu-tang clan it ain't
happening it ain't happening
ain't even even if you meet the perfect
person and it gonna be the perfect time
you're married they're single that's
right you're Jewish they're Palestinian
you're Mexican
they're a cool you're a black woman he's
a black man
[Applause]